[Müzik]
Merhaba arkadaşlar hoş geldiniz 16
yaşında ilk girişim mi kurduğumu
söyleyince arkadaşımız belki de böyle 23
yaşında birini beklediniz ama gördüğünüz
gibi bugünün en kıdemlilerinden biriyim
konuşmacılar arasında
niye buradayım Çünkü davet edildim
Sizlerde para ödediniz Onun için
buradasınız bari karşılığını verelim
size bugün bu kıdemden kaynaklı olarak
önemli bir şeyler söyleyeceğini
düşünüyor olabilirsiniz önemli şeyler
söyleyeceğim ama bu önemli şeyler
bazılarınız için belki çok önemli olacak
bazılarınız için daha az önemli olacak
tabi konuları dağıtırken arkadaşlar
en heyecanlı en sıkıntılı konuyu da bana
vermişler Dolayısıyla karşınızda hem
mutluyum hem de heyecanlıyım
şimdi 16 yaşında girişimci oldum ben
daha doğrusu girişimci olduğumu 23
yaşında öğrendim Niye Çünkü 16 yaşında o
girişimi gerçekten bir girişim olduğunu
bilmiyordum fakat ilk şirketimi
kurduğumda 23 yaşında bir girişim
olduğunu anladım bir çoğunuz farklı
coğrafyalarda yaşadığınız yetiştiniz
Benim büyüdüğüm coğrafya Aslında böyle
Ticaret kaslarının çok geliştirildiği
Hatta o kaslarınızı da göstereyim
yapabileceğiniz kadar geliştirildiği bir
coğrafyaydı haliyle çocukluktan bu yana
ticaret para
girişim gelir gider bu konularda biraz
şanslıydım açıkçası ama 23 yaşında ilk
şirketimi kurduktan sonra kendi bir
farklı bir şeyin içerisinde buldum bu
farklılık
bir oyun değişikliği bir oyun
değiştirici olma konusunda kendimi çok
ne denir iyi hissettirdi bana Dünyaya
baktım kendi coğrafyama baktım mahalleme
baktım sokağıma baktım ve bir oyunu
değiştirebileceğine inandım açıkçası Ve
kendimi de artık şu an itibariyle yarım
yüzyıla yakın bir ömür yaşamış biri
olarak Game Changer yani oyun değişik
değiştirici olarak görüyorum Tabi bu
ukala bitti Terim bir çoğunuz Neyi
Değiştirdin diyebilirsiniz gerçekten
Kendimi geçmişe doğru baktığımda birçok
şey değiştirdiğimi görebiliyorum artık
23 yaşından sonra çok hızlı şekilde
gelişti Hayat
Önümüzdeki Önümüzdeki hayatı içerisinde
çok fazla Hedef koymuştum o kadar fazla
Hedef vardı ki bunları gerçekleştirmek
için yeterli zamanında olmadığını
düşünüyordum
o yüzden hemen evlendim
eşim eşim de aranızda 28 yıllık evliyim
dolayısıyla çok hızlı bir hayatı Aslında
evlilikle başlattım ve girişimcilik
maceramda öyle başladı bu kadar ömüre
bir de 14 yıl kamuoyu sığdırmayı
başardım o tarafı da görmem gerekiyordu
çünkü haliyle böyle bir hayat hikayesi
olan biri var karşınızda Ama buna böyle
bir anda gelinmiyor Şöyle ki önce
dünyayı değiştirmeye 16 yaşında Karar
verdiğim zaman bu yaklaşık
45-44 yaşlarına kadar işte acaba
dünyayı değiştirebilir miyime dönüşüyor
bazen bazen diyorsunuz ki ya bugün
değiştirmeyeyim yarın değiştireyim bazen
de şimdi uyuyayım sonra değiştirir mi
dönüşüyor Ama dönüşte dönüşe dönüşe
tekrar O noktaya geri geliyor ve 50
yaşında kendimce
bir değişikliği yaptığıma inanıyorum
Tabii burada ekranda Hz Ruha Bir Gemi
yapmasını ilahî
girişimcilerle peygamberleri
özdeşleştirdim diyeceksiniz ki şimdi Ne
anlatacak bu
inanın iyi oldu Belki biraz sonra
anlatınca Siz de hak vereceksiniz şimdi
girişimci diye baktığımız zaman
insanlara Daha doğrusu girişimcilere
baktığımız zaman bir sorunu çözdüğünü
görüyorsunuz Bu sorunu nasıl çözmüş
neresinde duruyor Bu sorunun
hangi araçları kullanmış hangi
kaynakları kullanmış ihtiyaca nasıl
yaklaşmış böyle bakıyorsunuz yılların
deneyimiyle de aslında girişimcilerin
birçok sorunu
çözerken onları yaklaşırken
inanılmaz bir bilgi birikimi de de
yanına aldığını görüyorsunuz şimdi Hz
Nuh Büyük tufanda ne yaptı bir sorun
vardı
asimetrik bakmayı öğrendiğiniz zaman
Aslında
girişimciliği birçok şeyle
özdeşleştirebiliyorsunuz Ben de
peygamberlerle eşleştirdim Özellikle de
ruhla Peki Nuh ne yaptı Bütün araçları
bir araya getirdi kaynakları ve bir
prototip ortaya koymaya çalıştı aynı
girişimciler gibi girişimcilerde
kaynakları bir araya getiriyor Bu bazen
insan kaynağı bazen finansal kaynaklar
bazen de
ailesinden aldığı kaynaklarla bir
prototip oluşturmaya çalışıyor aynı ruh
gibi Peki Nuh Peygamber gemisini
yaparken
hatırlarsınız filmi veya hikayeyi ne
yapıyordu insanlar ona iman etmeyenler
onu da alay ediyorlardı şimdi aranızda
girişimciler vardır veya girişimci olmak
isteyenler vardır diye tahmin ediyorum
girişimcilere ne diyor ailelere
Öncelikle
Ya oğlum kızım yapma bu işi git bir SSK
ve
icat çıkarma başımıza bak maaş İyidir
sürekli sabit bir maaş İyidir
bir sürü sorun yaşayacaksın
Bu arada ben oğluma da bunu söylüyorum
Dolayısıyla bu engellerin dışında bir de
etrafından şöyle şeyler duyuyorsunuz
değil mi bu daha önce yapıldı
ya bu fikirde ne var ki
bunu daha önce yapanlar oldu Sen niye
yenisini yapıyorsun şimdi Tabii ki
burada inovasyon devreye giriyor haliyle
girişimci ortaya bir sorun bir sorunu
tespit ettikten sonra ortaya bir çözüm
koyuyorsa onu inovasyonla çözerek
aslında bir sonraki aşamaya geçiyor Siz
siz olun etrafın sözüne bakmayın icat
çıkarmaya devam edin tabi Burada inanç
ve istikrar gerçekten çok çok önemli
unsurlar Eğer bir girişimci
inandığı fikrinin arkasına daima giderse
buna ne diyoruz biz Tutku diyoruz Bu
tutkusunu sürekli sabit kılarsa ve bunda
da istikrarlı olursa sürekli yaparsa
bunu gerçekten sonuca ulaşıyor bunun
örneklerini çok fazla görüyoruz peki
şimdi Tabii girişimci ile bu
özdeşleştirme devam ediyor bu
peygamberlerle bu peygamber bu gemiyi
yaptıktan sonra ne yaptı çiftleri her
hayvandan her canlının bir çiftini
gemiye koydu ve bunlara yetecek kadar da
yiyeceği gemiye stokladı şimdi girişimci
tarafına döndük girişimci ne yaptı işte
fikrini ortaya koydu çözümünü ortaya
koydu daha sonraki aşamalarda
kaynaklarını birleştirdi bu kaynakları
doğru kaynaklar olarak planladı ve bir
sonraki aşamaya geçti prototipini
yapacak
prototipini yaptı ve bu kaynaklarla
beraber yoluna yürüyor yolunda yürüyor
Demek ki Nuh peygamberle yine
özdeşleştirmeye devam edebiliyoruz
gemi 150 gün sularda durdu şimdi bunu
nereden bağlarız girişimciye Şimdi hemen
empati kuracaksınız Demek ki sıralamada
girişimci prototipini oluşturduktan
sonra ne yapacak pazar doğrulaması
alması gerekiyor çünkü bu ürüne para
ödeyen var mı bu parayı niye ödüyor
hangi motivasyonla bu parayı
girişimcilere ödüyor tüketiciler hizmet
veya ürünlerde İşte biz buna pazar
doğrulaması diyoruz Demek ki bu prototip
150 gün suda kalmış ruhun gemisi ve O
Gemide kendini iş modelini ispat etmiş
haliyle modelin kanıtlanması aşamasını
da bu şekilde düşünebiliriz Peki daha
sonra tabii ki Büyümek gerekiyor
büyümek için girişimcinin yeni
kaynaklara ulaşması gerekiyor Bu
kaynakları temin etmesi için de ne
yapacak bazı araçlar kullanacak bu
araçlardan biri de tabii ki Türkiye'de
yeni başlayan işte biraz önce anons
edilmişti kitle fonduymuş halktan para
toplanması şimdi girişimciler Türkiye'de
ve dünyada farklı araçlardan
finansman toplayabiliyorlar Ama bu
topladıkları finansmanın doğru zamanda
doğru miktarda ve doğru maliyette olması
gerekiyor dünyadaki bütün gelişmiş
ülkelerdeki girişimcilik ekosistemine
baktığınız zaman bunu çok rahat
görebiliyorsunuz Şimdi burada da Nuh
Peygamber Tabii ki gemi dalgalarla
boğuşuyor haftalarca aylarca sularda
kalıyor ve bir güvercin salarak aslında
bir karar arıyor bir kaynak arıyor çünkü
burada yiyecekler kısıtlı
kaynaklar kısıtlı aynı girişimcilerde
olduğu gibi bu kaynağı ulaşmak her zaman
için kolay olmadığı gibi farklı
denemelerde yapmak gerekiyor
girişimciler yine
beni çok iyi anlayacaktır onlarca
yüzlerce yatırımcı görüşmeleri yapılır O
yatırımcı görüşmelerin genelde
%99.9'u olumsuz sonuçlanır haliyle bu
çabaların sürekli sürekli kılmak
zorundadırlar ve bu kaynağa ulaşmak için
çok fazla gayret sarf etmeleri gerekir
haliyle Nuh da yeni bir güvercin
gönderiyor Çünkü ilk güvercin başarısız
oldu karayı bulamadı ikinci güvercin ise
çok rahatlıkla
karaya ulaşıyor ve Bir zeytin dalıyla
dönüyor şimdi zeytin dalıyla döndükten
sonra tabii ki Kara görünmüş oluyor bu
karayı bulmak gerekiyor Nuh peygamberdi
bu karaya ulaştıktan sonra Orada bir köy
kuruyor
şimdi girişimciler kaynağa ulaştıktan
sonra hepimizin çok duyduğu Sertap
dediğimiz bir yapıya kavuşmuş oluyorlar
haliyle köy kurulmuş artık yaşam orada
başlamış oluyor tabi bitmiyor işler köy
kurulduktan sonra ne yapılacak büyüyecek
ve şu anda salonda Biz oturuyorsak ve Bu
hikayeye inanıyorsak Aslında hepimiz o
köylüysüz Nuh'un kurduğu o güvercin
dalının zeytin dalının güvercinin
getirdiği zeytin dalının
geldiği köydeniz hepimiz Haydi ile
girişimciler de bizden İçimizden
insanlar onların kaynağı erişim
konusundaki çabalarına hepimiz Aslında
toplum olarak da desteklemek zorundayız
Diğer taraftan baktığınızda ülkelerin
gelişmesi için istihdama ve üretimin
gelişmesi için girişimciliğin ülkelerde
çok gelişmesi gerekiyor böyle de buraya
bağlamış olayım Tabii köy büyüdük
dediğimiz startup skillab ve doğru
privatecota'ya giden bir yolculuk
başlıyor girişimciler ulaştıkları
kaynaklara bir sonraki kaynaklara
ulaşabilmek için kullanıyorlar böyle bir
Silsile devam ediyor Sonra da ne
duyuyoruz Aa şu şirket şu girişim
unicorn oldu decathorn Oldu
Peki şimdi burada
Size bir yemek tarifi versem
şöyle bir yemek olsun bu
girişimcilik yemeği olsun Bu harika bir
yemek bu yemeğin içerisine Tutku koyun
yeterince Tutku yeterince gayret
yeterince çaba yeterince Finans
yeterince mücadele bunların hepsini
birleştirin karıştırın ortaya
girişimcilik adında harika bir yemek
çıkıyor ve bu yemeği yiyen ülkeler
müthiş bir gelişim gösteriyor Diğer
taraftan hayallerinizden Biraz önce
anlattığım şekilde size kim ne derse
desin hayallerinizden asla ve asla
vazgeçmeyin burada olmak büyük bir
keyifti Ama şu Sözde bitirmek istiyorum
Büyük Tufan geldiğinde ruhun gemisinde
olmak yerine o muhteşem gemiyi inşa eden
takımda oyun değiştiren biri olarak sizi
görmek isterim Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]